a pharmaceutical salesman went
undercover to expose his company for
illegally marketing an addictive cancer
drug Bruce Boyce was tasked with
promoting
acti pain-killing lollipop containing
the opioid fentanyl for treatments not
approved by the FDA he worked with FDA
investigators to expose the practice
that put patients at risk of addiction
or accidental overdose in the season
finale of CBS's whistleblower judge a
former police officer and host Alex
Ferrer spoke with boys about what it
took to expose illegal marketing at the
dawn of the opioid epidemic every day
was different every day was exciting to
me until 2000 when Bruce boys a
pharmaceutical salesman at Cephalon was
ordered by his boss to promote drugs
off-label to doctors meaning for
purposes that were not approved by the
Food and Drug Administration in order to
boost sales it's not legal for a
pharmaceutical company to promote
off-label I didn't do very well at all
with selling off-label because my heart
just wasn't in it I didn't think it was
right so he took action and contacted
investigators at the FDA they wanted
proof his company was breaking the law a
couple agents sat down and talked to me
about what the company was doing and
asked me to bring material to show how
they were doing it in 2003 agents asked
boys if he'd wear a wire at a Cephalon
national sales meeting I thought if
that's what it took to stop a company
from doing what they're doing boys was
outraged when he heard a sales rep
describe how he was promoting act ich a
medical lollipop made with the extremely
powerful opioid fentanyl to general
practitioners fentanyl is a very strong
opioid it's about hundred times stronger
than morphine fentanyl is the drug that
killed Tom Petty and prints fentanyl is
very easy to overdose on the FDA had
approved act ich only for cancer
patients in acute uncontrolled pain a
very small market Cephalon though
pursued a much larger one they
eventually marketed for low back pain
and migraine patients
what problem did you have with that oh
that was trouble you you're talking
about a class two narcotic and you're
giving it to a migraine patient so it
puts patients at risk boys was fired
when the company learned he was working
with the FDA and then his fears about
promoting act eek for off-label use were
realized Robin Geist ouack a migraine
sufferer who took act eek to dull her
headaches became tragically addicted boy
I wish Robin had never taken that acting
I think she would still be alive
Peter Chatfield is boys's whistleblower
attorney in light of the opioid crisis
that we all know about would it be fair
to say that Bruce was the canary in the
coal mine I think with hindsight about
what has happened it absolutely was we
had never seen anything like that and
you can see what happened it took off
from there and Alex Ferrer joins us now
Alex good morning an opioid lollipop is
a serious thing so what are the FDA
learn putting a wire on a salesperson
that used to work with this product well
one of the things they learned was how
open and blatant this illegal activity
was it's illegal to market drugs
off-label for pharmaceutical company and
here was the director of marketing
standing on the stage at the national
sales meeting telling the entire sales
force are bragging about the fact that
they're selling all these different
drugs off-label which is illegal and one
of them act eek the one we're talking
about you know you had you had people
who were found basically dead with a
lollipop in their mouth because they
should not have been taking act ich or
incredibly powerful fentanyl is a
hundred times more powerful than
morphine right Alex thank you very much
scary stuff you can watch whistleblower
opioid lollipops the case against
Cephalon tonight it's part of a double
feature season finale that begins at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS